the owners and the and the commissioner  I don't know what their individual  politics are I don't think they  understand what's happening to him I  don't think they understand what's going  they're relating to the majority their  fan base they're not they're driving  them away and I hate it I don't want the  NFL to get smaller I don't want it to  become insignificant I don't want it to  be taken over by a bunch of wusses I  don't want it to be taken over by  left-wing social justice causes you know  use something besides the NFL sideline  use something besides a flag use  something besides something that people  use to escape everything left us they're  trying to force